Oh,
welcome to the grammar of words.
This is one of a number of linguistics lessons on the site and it will introduce
you to how language is build words.
We'll cover two basic topics in this lesson.
The first is going to be the components of words,
and the second will be a way to classify types of languages based on how they do
build words.
Two concepts to get you started.
The first is the morphine.
This is our basic building block in the grammar of words.
A morpheme is the smallest meaningful unit.
You can break a word down into each word has at least one morpheme,
so for instance,
the word dog is both a word and a morpheme.
It's the single morphine dog.
If you just break it down to the sound or the gusts sound,
you're no longer working with morphine's.
There were dogs in the plural.
More than one dog has to morphemes.
It has the morphine dog and it has a sound or a sound that tells you it's the
plural,
the morphine dog and the morphine plural.
Make the word dogs,
which has two morphine's.
A second concept to get you started is an Alan Moore and Ella morph is a
different way.
The same morpheme can show up.
We talk about morphemes as being a general underlying concept.
I gave you the example of dog with s and s oral morphine.
You can see that it makes the word plural.
If we had that same plural s to another word,
we sometimes see that it shows up differently.
For example,
in the word hats,
it shows up as an s sound and not as sound.
So the z sound in the s sound are two Allen morphs of a single plural as
morphine.
There are different types of morphine's there morphemes that can stand on their
own,
like the word dog.
These are known as free morphemes.
It doesn't have to be attached to another morpheme to be used morphemes that do
need to be attached to another morpheme to be used or known as bound.
Morphemes.
Take the example of plural s.
Do you ever say just s on its own domain?
Plural,
plural.
S always shows up at the end of other morphemes like in dogs that makes it a
bound morphine.
Two types of bound morphemes occur in English and a variety of other languages.
Derivational,
morphemes and inflectional.
Morphine's derivational morphemes allow you to form new words,
new concepts out of other morphemes inflectional morphemes conveyed grammatical
information.
An example would be the s in the word dogs that we've already talked about a few
times that conveys the grammatical information.
Hey,
this words plural,
so keep an eye out for both of these types.
Bound morphemes are generally bound in a fixed position with respect to the
morphine's.
They're attaching to morphemes that attach before another morpheme are known as
prefixes morphemes that occur after another.
Morpheme are known as suffixes.
There are other examples that actually occur inside of it,
either morphine that are called in fixes and bound morphemes that attach around
another morphine,
which we call circum fixes.
I guess you can say that these are a little more exotic.
All of these are known as affixes,
which is the Latin way of saying that they're attached to another word.
Languages have other techniques at their disposal for expressing grammatical
concepts.
One of these is a clinic which is kind of like a free morphine,
kind of like an ethics.
It sits alongside of and is pronounced along with the word that it grammatically
relates to a zero morpheme or a non morpheme is a morphine that doesn't get
pronounced.
This concept of US silent,
meaningful unit is strange at first.
I know we can argue for its existence based on the grammar of a language,
so knowing that English speakers differentiate between singular and plural,
it could be argued that dog actually carries a zero morphine.
So these two morphemes,
the free morpheme dog and the bound morpheme zero morpheme allow us to identify
the categories.
Singular Noun.
It's one dog and not multiple dogs.
Another fundamental concept is peripheral basis,
which uses multiple words to express the same grammatical concept that another
language might express using an inflection on morphine.
There's also compounding,
which takes two free morphemes and sets them side by side to represent a new
concept.
In that way.
It's kind of like attaching a derivational morpheme in a language that allows
it,
but the two morphemes are free.
So we can say for instance,
Dog House Dog House,
which attaches the free morpheme dog and the free morpheme house to come up with
a new concept.
Rearranging word order is also a useful technique that's very common for
expressing grammar.
We have some additional terminology for talking about languages that like to
bind morphine's.
The root morpheme is the base that carries most of the meaning.
Any derivational morphemes added to the root would help form the stem to which
affix is can be added inflectional.
Affixes would not be part of the stem and he derivational affixes.
However,
and the route itself would be part of the stem and if it's on its own,
it's both the root and the stem languages that tend to use bound morphemes are
known as synthetic languages because they tend to put morphemes together to form
words at the other end of the spectrum.
And analytic language does not use bound morphine.
So each word on average in an analytic languages of free morphine types of
languages that use bound morphemes include fusional languages,
which are rarer,
but basically fuse together information,
grammatical information into an inflection Atticus's.
So they tend to have a lot more meaning in their affixes and fewer affixes,
whereas a gluten native languages tend to have more affixes,
but less overlap between grammatical meanings in each individual athletes.
This lesson has covered morphine's,
Alan morphs,
and very roughly how different individual languages build outwards with
morphine's.
Be sure to check out the page for more information and exercises and I'll catch
you in the next lesson.